welcome ladies and gentlemen uh if
you're intrigued by cryptography you're
in the right place our next talk is uh
titled encrypted uh computation what if
decryption wasn't needed we're joining
here today by Katherine jarmo principal
data scientist at Fu Works let's welcome
her with a round warm of Applause and
Catherine the floor is yours thank you
Johan awesome so um I hope you're ready
for some cryptography first I would like
to ask is anybody in this room a
cryptographer or has studied
cryptography yes one and a half maybe
more um cool so today we're going to
talk about a field called encrypto
computation this is a field that I
worked in for a long time I'm going to
try to give you an overview of the field
and it's going to be a little bit fast
so um if we run out of time for
questions please come find me afterwards
I'm very excited to talk about this
field so um what I want you to think
about today and what I want to open the
possibility of is what if we could do
data science and machine learning on
encrypted data what if we actually never
ever needed to decrypt the data in order
to run the models that we're going to do
or in order to make inferences analytics
queries any types of things that we'd
like to do and I'm here to tell you not
only is it possible it is already
running in production in many
situations so what is the field of
encrypted computation uh first and
foremost it opens up new possibilities
for us so here we're kind of exploring
what will be possible if we could do all
of this on encrypted data um first and
foremost my favorite use case currently
we have a ton of insecure data sharing I
make an agreement with your company we
decide to share data we do all of that
in plain text what is preventing you
from using that data doe to something
else contractual agreements we have
literally no technical measures usually
in place when we form these data sharing
agreements other than there is some
semblance of human trust cool thing
about encrypted computation we can model
human trusts in technological trusts in
cryptography that is essentially the
whole purpose of
cryptography um another thing that we
can do is a lot of times the sensitive
data that we'd like to use and if you've
been working in data science for as long
as I have or even some number of years
you probably notice the more sensitive
data has interesting information to
solve difficult problems when we think
about healthc care when we think about
Finance when we think about the things
if you were at my keynote this morning
government NGO we're talking often about
highly sensitive data we're talking
about using that for things like machine
learning or statistical modeling and for
that we need to try to hopefully provide
some type of security and privacy for
the people
involved another thing we can do in
encrypted computation is we can
explicitly Define the privacy and
security rules and properties that we
want to see in the processes and the
computations that we run and we can
validate and verify those within our
computation this is not not possible if
we were just lazily doing plain text
this is only possible when we have
strict definitions and rules around at
what point in time we can do things like
see the plain text unveil the Plaine
text and therefore we can also U model
this in so so-called logic that allows
us to then prove that indeed the system
is following the rules correctly and
finally uh concept near and dear to me
we want to empower users with their own
privacy so we want to give users the
ability to share data with us without
know without essentially us being able
to see the data and encrypto computation
allows us to do all of these things and
in the center of it is uh if you're here
because you like math maybe um in the
center of it there's some really cool
math properties of cryptography
obviously and uh we can call it magic
but as we know from machine learning um
or as you probably know from all of your
work in mathematics up to this point
it's actually not magic it's just math
so the first thing I'm going to show you
is an application that's already running
it's hugging face which I'm assuming we
have some familiarity with in this room
and uh it uses also an open source
library from concrete ml that is a
product of Zama and Zama AI is a group
of cryptographers that are based in
Paris who are working on some pretty
cool machine learning problems so we're
going to go to the hugging space so you
can run this on your own uh this is a
hugging fa a hugging a hugging face
space and this hugging face space allows
you to do some basic sentiment analysis
with encrypted tensors so the first
thing that we need to do is generate
Keys we can then provide a message so I
really like
encryption I
think and we'll try to give it something
a little bit more tricky we're going to
encode quantize and encrypt
the initial
embedding and then we're going to run
the FHA evaluation more on this later
but the FH stands for fully homomorphic
encryption it eventually runs and we
have our encrypted predictions so as you
can see here is a encrypted Vector um
and then at the end we can decrypt it on
our side and we see that 72% positive
and so on and so forth and so this is
already running you can actually test
this out yourself
but you might be wondering to yourself
how does this actually work well I want
to start to give you a mental model to
work through that could maybe help you
understand homomorphic encryption and
then we'll move to other forms of
encrypted computation the most important
thing obviously is the homomorphisms of
the properties themselves and this is
best shown in
commutativity which is harder for me to
say now that I know German because
somehow my brain wants to turn it into
commun tivity and that's not right um
and so we have our inputs which here in
plain teex space or our X and our output
Y and we have our Cipher text across the
bottom C1 and C2 and the commutativity
property allows us to uh move between
Cipher text space and plain text space
and perform functions that end up
creating the same properties now those
functions may need to be shifted
slightly when we're working in encrypted
space but the concept of homomorphism
allows us to perform end up performing
the same amount of operations in
encrypted space as in PL Tech space and
to make sure that we end up with the
same result so the cool thing about when
we think about encrypted computation in
comparison with some of the other
privacy Technologies like differential
privacy is we are not reducing our
accuracy in order to get the solution
however it is more expensive more on
that in a
second so how does it actually work what
I thought is we'd walk through an
example of pader so pet encryption is
one example of pal of a homomorphic
encryption or crypto system encryption
scheme and here is the basic equation
that we use for Paller to encode or
encrypt data so first we have our
encryption message uh that's the m and
that's in plain text of course we've
also
uh created it in some sort of binary
space or some sort of bite
representation and that's what we take
as our message we have G which is our
finite group base so I don't know how
many people here have studied much of
group Theory or finite fields or number
Theory but yes but this is your group
right and um that's an important U
method and thinking through cryptography
because quite a lot of the cool crypto
math is based around groups and things
like modular arithmetic and so on and so
forth then we have our Randomness R and
we're not going to get into how that's
sampled but there's particular ways that
we need to sample that and then we mod
our N squared and our n is our modulus
it's generally a large Prime and if you
know group Theory it divides the order
of G so in this case because P um allows
us only to do one type of homomorphic
encryption or one type of homomorphic
property which means it's par
homomorphic encryption um we're going to
to kind of cheat and take a shortcut
we're going to choose a large Prime n
and then we're going to add one and
we're going to get G and that's how we
can Define our group base and our
Prime and the cool thing is is we can
immediately see we're going to take an
encrypted message one we're going to
take an encrypted message two we're
going to multiply them together and
through some fairly simple algebra we're
going to Define find or figure out that
when we take encrypted message one so
Cipher text one and we multiply it by
Cipher text 2 we actually end up with
the cipher text of M1 plus M2 so the
addition of our two original messages we
get by multiplying the cipher text
together and this will always work um
which is pretty cool but you don't have
to just trust me we can try it out so in
uh I wrote I wrote a book called
practical data privacy in it there's an
entire chapter on encrypted computation
it goes much more into details than
we'll have a chance to do today but as
part of building that chapter I've also
built a series of Jupiter notebooks that
are available online that you can use to
play around with these Concepts and so
this notebook has a little bit more
above it of defining a variety of
functions and showing you a little bit
of how Fields work but uh today we'll
just start start with generating the
keys sampling Randomness oh can you see
this is it big enough hold
on maybe that's better you tell me in
the back row can you see it okay um so
we have our encryption key so we can see
I have n defined I have n s defined and
I have G
defined I can sample my Randomness via a
particular method I can take a message
of four I can encrypt the message of
four I can see that the four is
encrypted I can decrypt the message and
I get the
results now you're like Katherine okay I
can encrypt on my own I don't need your
jupyter notebook to encrypt things okay
yes this is very very true um however
maybe you're intrigued or interested in
the actual homomorphic properties um so
all this is written with a cryptographer
that I know so it is definitely correc
is and uh you can use it to play around
and maybe you're curious about some of
the mathematical operations so all of
it's been written in as easy as I can
write python for you to go through but
we take our first message we take our
second message we sample Randomness for
our two different Cipher texts we encode
these or encrypt these essentially into
Cipher texts we have our two Cipher
texts we add them together we get the
result also in Cipher text and we
decrypt them and we indeed see that it
is equal to the same plate Tex operation
we can also subtract them and we indeed
get the same
operation we can also one cool thing
about pier and several of other of the
homomorphic encryption schemes that are
even only partially homomorphic is we
can also do as many plain text
operations as we want so we can take
encrypted text we can multiply plain
texts we can add PL text we can divide
PL text we can subtract PL text and we
end up getting the same result so we can
go through times 5 minus a th000 plus a
very large number well a partially large
number so it's very cool
no no yes no okay maybe partially cool
so we'll uh we'll keep going we'll learn
a bit
more so I want to give you a brief recap
so homomorphic encryption what is it it
allows you essentially to perform these
types of mathematical operations on
Cipher text without having to decrypt it
at any point in time the decryption key
is yourself or you have it yourself so
we can think of it in like a user and an
owner and an operator situation we could
have a situation where only one of these
people has the decryption key and
therefore only one of these people is
allowed to decrypt the result and um
there's some pretty cool things so these
are all properties of a particular
crypto scheme not all crypto schemes are
homomorphic obviously and some crypto
schemes provide what we call fully
homomorphic uh evaluation or uh
encryption and others that only do
partial so paer which I showed you today
uh we don't actually recommend using it
anymore because it's based on
factorization as the hard problem which
of course will eventually one day be
non-quantum safe but it's still a fun
place to get started and to see but Pier
will only ever support these additive
and subtractive properties therefore
when you get into more complex crypto
schemes that allow you to do
multiplicative operations or what we
call evaluations on circuits of
arbitrary depth which basically just
means arbitrary complexity length and uh
difficulty of the operation these are
when you get into the really interesting
problems and this is what uh Zama AI for
example is working
on some of the problems in homomorphic
encryption that we've encountered in the
field so to speak is that for these
operations to perform at any relative
amount of speed you might require
Hardware accelerations so for example
Zama as well as several other Microsoft
has a group that also works on
homomorphic encryption um they are often
working with fpga developers and other
types of people that are creating
specialized hardware for specialized use
cases to run this at scale there's also
some homomorph encryption uh protocols
or operations that are just easier so if
you can Define the problem with with
nonarbitrary depth but with a particular
amount of what we call circuit depth
then you can also speed it up by just
designing the problem slightly
differently and again just to repeat
homomorphic encryption is really awesome
when you have you're a processor you
want to offer your user or the data
owner or whoever it is a way to use your
processing without having to decrypt
their data homomorphic encryption is
actually a great fit for those types of
problems
okay secure multiparty computation so
homomorphic encryption is a part of
encrypted computation how many people in
this room had already heard of
homomorphic encryption at least
once yes okay a a a smattering if you
will how many people have heard of MPC
or secure
multiparty more than normal yeah yes
okay so MPC is actually the space of
cryptography that I had the pleasure of
working in um uh it has a lot of cool
properties that are very different than
homomorphic encryption in that by
default MPC schemes involve multiple
players there is no way of building a
multi-party computation without having
multiple parties and the cool thing is
is that it has some significant
performance improvements in compared to
homomorphic encryption so in instead of
essentially having to perform all of our
operations on these very very large
sometimes uh Cipher teexs we're actually
providing them or performing them on
things that we can size more reasonably
often called things like secret shares
or other types of operations where we
might trade between MPC and homomorphic
encryption um another cool thing is
because it automatically has multiple
parties is great for data sharing use
cases so in the area that I worked in in
in encrypted uh machine learning we were
often dealing with situations where we
had multiple data providers that would
like to train a model together but there
wasn't full trust between all of the
data providers maybe they were
competitors maybe they were you can
imagine uh Fields where they were
vertically in integrated like Supply
chains and so forth and they might want
to share data to solve a problem but
they definitely don't want to share
their data in plain text because it
could involve some sort of competitive
problem between the different data
contributors and uh so this makes it
really really great for things like data
sharing cases or other things where
multiple people that might have a
variety of levels of trust of one
another can decide to compute together
and all benefit or at least decide who
gets to benefit from the
result it's uh based on the same
mathematics so a lot of the same ground
principles of number Theory as well as
abstract algebra apply for MPC um but
the cool thing is is like we move away
from this kind of old well it's not old
mindset but this mindset where we need
to have a public and a private key in
MPC there's a different way that we kind
of model these problems but we still
have the ability to decide when and how
we decrypt and who is allowed to
decrypt okay so you might be thinking
okay all of this sounds cool from a
theoretical perspective but how can we
actually imagine
what we can use this for well uh the
field that near and dear to my heart is
encrypted machine learning and I want to
kind of break it down into two boxes for
you one of them is where we actually
want to train an encrypted model on
encrypted data and that is this big
bucket of encrypted training and one
which is which we call usually encrypted
or private inference and this is where
we just want to use maybe a model that's
been trained on Plain text maybe that's
been slightly altered so that I can
handle whatever C Cipher text we're
giving it but P primarily a plain text
model that we then want to show an
encrypted Tor or embedding or something
like this and actually run a prediction
on it that only one or multiple people
can decrypt based on how we've formed
the problem and that's very much like
what the hugging face Zama interface
does is very strongly in the encrypted
inference where they've made some very
slight changes to the way that the
initial input layers work on the hugging
face models and everything else Remains
the Same other than now it can run on
encrypted uh
tensors for encrypted training what's
really cool I mainly worked in MPC again
this is where I would strongly say
distributed or decentralized use cases
where you have multiple people that
would like to contribute data as part of
your model training this is where it
really works and because in MPC we have
the tradeoff we have less compute
overhead but we have more interaction
which basically means more Network um
more latency problems when we move
people to the same Cloud let's say you
have multiple people on Azure together
or something like this we can actually
significantly reduce the latency
overhead and therefore we can actually
quite often speed up MPC use cases to
near production times that you would
normally do especially if you're doing
batch training or something like this
and you don't need to do any type of
realtime training which almost nobody is
doing
anyways um for homomorphic encryption it
again again is you're going to have to
start to make some trade-offs and this
is mainly because homomorphic encryption
you're going to need to think about
Hardware accelerators you're going to
think about specialized hardware and
you're going to potentially move into an
area of homomorphic encryption that's
been growing um with certain protocols
where you essentially want to make
tradeoffs and say we're going to lose
some accuracy because we're going to
allow for an increase of noise in our
Cipher Tex because one of the most
expensive operations in homomorphic
encryption is is the reduction of the
noise that happens over time after many
many many operations on the cipher
text one of the areas that I had a
chance to work in as well is thinking
through we have a distributed or a
Federated machine learning problem and
we would like to create some sort of
updates or Aggregates across all of our
users or across a few disparate groups
who would like to train a model together
uh one of the cool things is uh that you
can look up and that's also of course in
the book is secure aggregation so the
idea of secure aggregation in Federated
learning is the ability for us to send
our updates whether it's a vectorized
form of the weights that are encrypted
or whether it's a particular gradient
update that's encrypted we can send the
updates to the aggregator the aggregator
is in charge of working on those updates
deciding okay we're going to move in
this direction we're going to send this
update to everybody and update the
global or the shared model and then send
it back out again and what we can
actually do is we can formul this
problem so that all of the updates that
are sent are encrypted that the
aggregator has a protocol or an ability
to decrypt that only after let's say the
Federated average is computed and then
everybody can get the update and
continue learning together so this is
pretty cool thing and uh I worked with a
team that created the first secure
aggregation for TF Federated if you want
to talk about
it another cool thing that can that you
can do that you might not know that you
can do and is actively a part of the
Google ad um let's say product if you we
can name Google as a product is private
set intersection otherwise known as
private joints what we can do with
private set intersection is we can take
a group of identifiers that one company
has with a group of identifiers that
another company has of course these have
to overlap in plain text space as well
we can encrypt them and we can share
them using a variety of protocols and we
can actually end up finding the
intersection in cyer text so we don't
have to actually reveal the plain text
in order to find the intersection and
for example in Google ads what they
might be curious about I don't know but
maybe what they might be curious about
is users that clicked an ad along with
users that bought something and they're
trying to find this intersection why are
they trying to find the intersection
well at some point in time they like to
potentially think through Roi or the
value of a particular ad or the
influence of a particular ad so
particularly when we're dealing with off
offline sales and online ads was the
influence of uh online ads and offline
sales this is a hard problem right and
so some one of the ways that they've
been able to do this is finding these
joins with the private set intersection
and one of the things you can do then is
you can then decrypt and then both sides
know the people that bought something
and the people that clicked but what you
can also actually do is you stay in
encrypted space and you keep Computing
and you just take that encrypted
essentially Union that you have and you
have encrypted and encoded the other
information such as the sales data or
the click data and then at that point in
time in encrypted space you can do
things like calculate the average you
could do so even with differential
privacy if you'd like to like add some
anonymity to the process and then you
can decide who gets to decrypt and who
gets to see the final Roi and all of
this is possible and running in the
Google ads ecosystem today for
particular use
cases but moving beyond we can do other
things we can do things like encrypted
auctions um this is something that the
Zama colleagues recently worked on where
for a variety of cryptocurrencies they
wanted to create encrypted options where
people can create encrypted bids where
the top bid can be evaluated in
comparison with the other encrypted bids
um we can even validate that indeed the
bid that you sent is yours and that you
were the one that encrypted it there's a
few methods to do that and then finally
we can decrypt and reveal um the top bid
this is also how the Danish beat auction
ran uh now more than 10 years ago is
encrypted auctions in an MPC setup
there's numerous other use cases you
might be familiar with the problem you
have you have people or you at your work
you have on Prem data you want to move
it to the cloud you are not allowed to
move it to the cloud for a variety of
reasons uh privacy maybe being one
security policy or proprietary data
policy being another another thing that
we can do is we can think about what
functions can we encrypt and then move
to the Cloud for elastic processing and
then move back to on-prem and
decrypt we can also do this in any type
of distributed operations so
particularly when we think of MPC and
maybe inspired by a keynote this morning
if you have critical problems that
you're trying to solve like energy good
problems housing problems uh education
problems you would like people to
contribute data that is extremely
sensitive to them how are you going to
actually get people to want to
contribute this data think about form
the problem in a way where they never
have to share data without uh a knowing
exactly what the security Protocols are
and be never sharing data without it
being
encrypted a few things uh so I'm
starting to run out of time but I wanted
to give you a few things that you're
going to learn I hope maybe a few of you
are inspired maybe you're intrigued um I
want to tell you some things that you're
going to learn if you decide to go on
this journey from data science into
cryptography um first you're going to
become an expert at noticing
optimization and performance problems
and trying to shape your problem into
ways that will actually work in
cryptography um which is pretty cool
you're also going to start thinking
about combining approaches and this may
mean sitting with cryptographers if you
get a chance to work with them but this
may also be sitting with libraries and
cryptography that are available and
start thinking through okay is this a h
problem is this MPC problem is this a
circuit problem how can we combine these
approaches and make sure that we have
the most optimal solution
you're going to learn all about finite
Fields so you're going to be moving from
floating Point arithmetic to fix Point
arithmetic for most of our stuff
especially like the the buffer sizes
that we have now for most of our compute
you're going to be fine but the one
thing you're going to think about is if
you're dealing with problems that get
really really small numbers or really
really big numbers you're going to get
errors and so you're going to have to
start thinking about how you shape your
problems so that um they're scaled to
fit the encrypted space you're going to
learn about about security models like
how do I think through does this need to
be passive security does this need to be
active security what is the relationship
between the different people that are
contributing data how can I think
through threat modeling and also
security paradigms to actually properly
form this problem and the most fun thing
is you're going to learn how to debug on
data that you have no idea what it is
and that you cannot see which is as fun
and as difficult as it
sounds um uh you can check my book if
you'd like to um I hope maybe you're
inspired to look at privacy enhancing
Technologies and learn more about
encrypted computation I've heard that
there's some reading groups that have
formed around my book at a variety of
different workplaces so maybe it's a
good way I've I've heard good feedback
that it helps to learn with others
especially when you're sitting and going
through some of this code to have
somebody else to talk with so if you
want to form a reading group um I would
encourage you to do so and I've I've uh
been invited and go talk to some reading
groups that have formed at a variety of
companies and then finally uh check out
Z's concrete as well as there's a few
other open source libraries that I would
recommend and again every chapter in the
book has at least one Jupiter notebook
if not many and so I hope you'll find
some inspiration there uh I hope that uh
that was exciting for you that maybe you
learned something you can always reach
out at any time and I will take I hope I
have time for like maybe at least one
question thank you very
much